[Music]
is she turning towards you or away from
you no one can agree
she's the mysterious subject of Dutch
master Yan Vermeer's girl with the Pearl
Earring a painting often referred to as
the Mona Lisa of the north belonging to
a Dutch style of idealized sometimes
overly expressive paintings known as
tronie z-- the girl with the Pearl
Earring has the allure and subtlety
characteristic of Vermeer's work but
this painting stands apart from the
quiet narrative scenes that we observed
from afar in many of Vermeer's paintings
a girl reading a letter a piano lesson a
portrait artist at work
these paintings give us a sense of
intimacy while retaining their distance
a draw and curtain often emphasizes this
separation we can witness a milkmaid
serenely pouring a bowl of milk but that
milk isn't for us we're only on lookers
the studied composition in Vermeer's
paintings invokes a balanced harmony
with the checkered floor in many of his
works
Vermeer demonstrates his command of
perspective and foreshortening that's a
technique that uses distortion to give
the illusion of an object receding into
the distance
other elements like sight lines mirrors
and light sources describe the moment
through space and position the woman
reading a letter by an open window is
precisely placed so the window can
reflect her image back to the viewer
Vermeer would even hide the leg of an
easel for the sake of composition the
absence of these very elements brings
the girl with the Pearl Earring to life
Vermeer's treatment of light and shadow
or chiaroscuro uses a dark flat
background to further spotlight her
three dimensionality instead of being
like a set piece in a theatrical
narrative scene she becomes a
psychological subject her eye contact
and slightly parted lips as if she is
about to say something draw us into her
gaze traditional subjects of portraiture
were often nobility or religious figures
so why was a Vermeer painting an
anonymous girl in the 17th century the
city of Delft
like the Netherlands in general had
turned against ruling aristocracy and
the Catholic Church after eight decades
of rebellion against Spanish power the
Dutch came to favor the idea of
self-rule and a political republic
cities like Delft were unsupervised by
Kings or bishops so many artists like
Vermeer were left without traditional
patrons fortunately business innovation
spearheaded by the Dutch East India
Company transformed the economic
landscape in the Netherlands it created
a merchant class and new type of patron
wishing to be represented in the
paintings they financed these merchants
preferred middle-class subjects depicted
in spaces that looked like their own
homes surrounded by familiar objects the
maps that appear in Vermeer's paintings
for example were considered fashionable
and worldly by the merchant class of
what is known as the Dutch Golden Age
the oriental turban worn by the girl
with the Pearl Earring also emphasizes
the worldliness of the merchant class
and the pearl itself a symbol of wealth
is actually an exaggeration Vermeer
couldn't have afforded a real pearl of
its size it was likely just a glass or
tin drop varnished to look like a pearl
this Mirage of wealth is mirrored in the
painting itself in greater context the
pearl appears round and heavy but a
detailed view shows that it's just a
floating smudge of paint upon close
inspection we are reminded of Vermeer's
power as an illusion maker while we may
never know the real identity of the girl
with the Pearl Earring we can't engage
with her portrait in a way that is
unforgettable
as she hangs in her permanent home in
the mountains House Museum in The Hague
her presence is simultaneously
penetrating and subtle in her enigmatic
way she represents the birth of a modern
perspective on economics politics and
love
Oh
[Music]